joining us now he's the chief counsel
for the American Center for Law and
Justice he's also one of the president's
attorneys exclusive tonight Jay Sekulow
let me start with a simple question your
take on all of this well on the you know
it's not surprising that there was an
indictment that came down and Paul
Manafort situation because that had been
anticipated for a number of weeks I mean
it's been speculated in the press you
had the the no-knock search of his house
which raises a whole host of
constitutional issues and then when you
look at the context of the indictment
and you read through it you realize that
the basis upon which the indictment is
rendered has nothing to do with the
campaign or campaign activities of the
president but rather involves business
transactions and activities that Paul
metaphor was allegedly engaged in in his
business going back to 2006 so you have
to look at these issues and on the basis
of the documents that have been produced
in the document that's been produced
right now is the indictment and as I
said that indictment focuses in on the
business activities and corporate
activities of Paul Mann affords and not
focus in on at all with regard to the
campaign or campaign activities to the
president so I think that's it that's a
big takeaway from this when you you look
at the nature and the scope of the fact
that it's been known for a number of
weeks that Paul manna Ford was a
principal target of this so again not
surprising surprising that there was a
leak of a sealed indictment however or
at least that's what CNN was reporting
well I don't know I mean that this this
idea that an indictment would be that
sealed number one would be leaked as a
crime in and of itself and you know I
don't know who was responsible for
leaking it I just know that it was
reported and as you reported that I
guess Paul man affords lawyers did not
know until yesterday late yesterday
evidently that they were the subject of
that indictment so again that raises
another issue and why in the world would
there be a leak of an indictment
especially a indictment that sealed and
why do you seal it indictment they were
concerned about flight risk
there's there's there's a list in the
justice manual yeah all right so the
media is going obsessed I know everybody
in the Trump campaign you know how
active a
I wasn't the campaign invested I was and
the media was ready to say Hannity is
wrong and his career is over it didn't
happen my obituary was written
Papadopoulos I never heard of him
I'm told he's a volunteer he's 29 years
old yeah maybe worked for Muller from
July on remand I know I never heard of
the guy until today thought yeah so
so here's well here's what this is what
I know I I don't know him either
I do know this that based on the reports
that I've seen that he was a part of a
committee of Foreign Affairs Committee
that are typical with this was during
the campaign season these campaigns have
a lot of committees and there's a lot of
people on these committees they they
generally do advisory work but they're
not paid staffers they're not it's not a
organized structure as you would think
of a you know in for instance and within
the State Department this was a
volunteer and what he did or did not do
is also interesting in the document
because what did he get charged for was
it he get charged for contacting some
ended some professor that was supposedly
Russian that's at least the allegation
in the in the documents that his plea
agreement that a side know what he got
charged with was lying to a federal
agent when asked the question about the
timing of those meetings and whether he
was a member of this committee that
suggested that they said no and nobody
knew who the guy was yes but again this
is that the FBI didn't fit or the
special counsel didn't indict here for
his conversation that he had with a
purportedly someone that had some Russia
affiliation this professor but they
indicted him for what were pleading for
what that was lying to an agent right
okay we got when I was 18 USC 1001 all
right thanks Sean